David Cassidy was the world's biggest
teen idol well last week the Partridge
Family star made headlines when he
announced that he was battling dementia
but many wondered was his battle with
the bottle part of the reason for the
diagnosis now David is opening up to dr.
Phil and Cameron Matheson has the
details he flatly denies that there was
any alcohol involvement in that
whatsoever
before or during the performance David
is blaming that disastrous performance
outside of La ten days ago when he was
slurring his words and stumbling onstage
on dementia details dr. Phil tomorrow
the disease was diagnosed over two years
ago what was the first symptom that you
noticed when friends of yours or family
members begin to say to you remember I
just told you this two days ago and
there is no memory of it that's when I
began to be very concerned was that what
caused you to say I need to go get
myself checked oh my god yes
but dr. Phil is somewhat skeptical about
David's claims of sobriety that night a
lot of professionals I've talked to felt
like that behavior was more consistent
with intoxication is that sort of
amplify in a sense the symptoms of
dementia it certainly does if you
introduce toxins of any sort to the
brain when it is diseased that's a bad
combination
David's dementia was foreshadowed years
earlier Cassidy's mother actress Evelyn
Ward died of Alzheimer's related
dementia in 2012 at the age of 89 what's
your greatest fear for the future as you
as you continue on this path being in
the place that my mother was the last
two years of her life where I would
completely disappear and I'd just be a
burden to caretakers and couldn't walk
couldn't talk couldn't sing couldn't
play that's kind of my greatest fear
actually are you having trouble
performing you know as for David's
assessment of his now infamous show I
asked him how he felt the concert went
he thought it went just terrific
[Music]
you